i know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said
this is absurd
sign this too
[Music]
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
mommy i need your unique low-key
perspective do i get a weapon
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
mike it is adorable
that you think you could possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we got our very first
full length trailer for the loki series
that is coming to disney plus
this trailer is just packed with easter
eggs and it gives us a lot more
information on what exactly is going to
be happening in this series
there are many important things to go
over in this trailer like the
tva and who exactly is our specific loki
that we're going to be following
throughout this series
why does the tva exactly need this
specific loki's help or any loki at all
for the matter of fact
we see female loki and a few other
versions of loki all throughout this
trailer and they're also big connections
to ant-man quantum mania where we know
that they're going to be introducing
kang the conqueror
and obviously some connections to thor
love and thunder as well
i have some more captain america shield
giveaways coming up soon so be sure to
subscribe so you can enter that giveaway
and so you can get all the latest mcu
videos so we start off right away with
loki being captured and taken to the
tva's headquarters so this takes place
right after avengers end game where loki
stole the tesseract and disappeared as
you can see he's wearing the same exact
suit and the guard that has captured him
has the tesseract in her hand
we then get a better look at the inside
of the tva and we get a look at the
three statues which are
the time keepers the original founders
of the tva
and speaking of connections to ant-man
quantomania at one point in time king
the conqueror is believed to be a time
keeper he has done many things
throughout many different timelines
because king the conqueror
is the master of time time travel and
loki says he actually knows what this
place is and the time keepers have built
quite the circus
and we actually see the three faces of
the time keepers again behind gugu mumba
raw
and her character has still yet to be
revealed to us but it's clear that she
works for the tva
there is speculation that she could
perhaps be ravenna langsliger who at one
point in time was a love interest of
kang the conqueror
now as we go through the tva through the
different scenes we can see many
different hourglasses on some of the
walls and some of the doors and there
are clocks just
everywhere and if you notice they all
have different times because they are
for different timelines now we hear owen
wilson finally talk about what the tva
actually does and he says the tva
protects the proper flow of time and
this is a direct callback to what the
ancient one was telling professor hulk
in avengers endgame she was specifically
talking about how the infinity stones
all together created what they perceived
as the flow of time and if you removed
one of the infinity stones
essentially everything would go to chaos
which is what we see here in this
trailer when they show us different
timelines this is all due
to loki taking the tesseract taking the
space stone out of that main timeline
the flow of time for the main timeline
has been disrupted and is now thrown
into chaos and these other timelines are
being thrown into chaos as well
as you can see on this screen where they
show the main timeline and the branches
breaking off
now owen wilson's character is mobius m
mobius and in the series he seems to be
the one that is in charge of the tva
and he tells loki that he needs his help
to fix it and when loki asks why he says
i need your
unique loki perspective now the reason
that he needs
this unique loki perspective is because
in each of these variant
timelines loki is the main problem and
the reason they're all going into chaos
now they are different versions of loki
like the female loki that we see many
many times throughout the trailer that
we'll talk about in just a second
we have president loki that is shown in
one scene and then there are just
other variations of different timelines
where loki is at the center of the chaos
so they are essentially using
r loki that is the main star of the show
to track down and defeat
different versions of himself in other
timelines because remember that's what
the tva's job is protecting the flow of
time
making sure one timeline does not affect
another timeline
but also making sure all timelines are
okay loki gets dumped into an office
where we see a man with his cat
and he shows us that the tva keeps
record of literally everything
anybody says at any point in time
throughout their entire lives he says
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said
then he says this is absurd and a new
paper prints out because he said more
words so he has to sign
for those new words as well but on this
piece of paper we actually learned
something here
at the very top of the new piece of
paper it says variant
l1130 the l obviously standing for loki
and the 1130 obviously being the variant
that this loki is because this is not
the main
loki the main loki is our main loki from
the main
avengers timeline our main mcu timeline
this is the same loki that got killed by
thanos during avengers infinity war so
that was the main loki from the main
timeline and any other loki that exists
in a different timeline is just a
variant of that main loki including the
one that we're going to be following
throughout this show
we even hear a character at one point in
time say you really believe in this loki
variant again calling him a variant
because he's not the true loki he even
wears a jacket that says variant on the
back of it now the main antagonist
of the show besides this actual loki
himself because remember this isn't the
same
mature loki that we knew that died in
avengers infinity war that went through
thor ragnarok and essentially his
redeeming arc this is a loki who just
got taken after the events of avengers
end game still a very evil loki
so he will be a hero and antagonist
himself but the main antagonist looks to
be
female loki some people thought that
this could be black widow in the scene
where loki is sitting right next to her
but it's more like him
talking to himself which is going to be
a very very interesting scene to see
just because loki is very clever and
this female version of himself the one
that tends to wear the hood seems to be
very smart clever and quick
so it'll be interesting to hear her
motive for doing everything
now the tva seems to travel throughout
different points of time through these
doors and at one point in time it looks
like female loki gets one of the guards
and is able to open a door for her to go
through this is most likely the main
loki that the tva is trying to capture
and why they need
our loki's help now we go through many
different alternate timelines that we
see throughout this trailer and then at
the end we can see loki holding his arms
up
looking at owen wilson's character
mobius and there's a big explosion and a
lot of dust coming at them in the
background this is no doubt loki
trying intentionally to mess everything
up and then it brings us to the scene of
loki stating that he's trustworthy but
of course owen wilson has seen every
part of his life and says i've literally
seen you stab people in the back
like 50 times and in true loki lying
fashion he states and i never do it
again
showing us more of his loki qualities
the deceptor the snake
the god of mischief now one other thing
to note is that in one of the scenes we
actually see
loki send sort of a blast of his green
magic out
this is something that we really haven't
seen before in the mcu it's kind of like
a
wanda blast so hopefully this will be
exploring more of his actual
magic in this series and this series has
been confirmed already for a season two
and given all the different directions
they could go with the different
timelines and the different variants of
loki
that is just awesome not to mention it's
probably going to tie in
a little bit to thor love and thunder
considering the fact that mjolnir has to
make its way back to the main timeline
after captain america put
it back it's been rumored that loki is
responsible for that but if i hear
anything else i'll be sure to make a
video on it so be sure to subscribe and
hit the notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos in
the meantime let me know your favorite
part from
this trailer in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you